cómo y cuándo los necesiten.
Vamos a acercarnos a Sierra Leona,
un país de seis millones de personas,
en el que un estudio reciente mostró que solo hay 10 cirujanos calificados.
Esto es un cirujano por cada 600 000 personas.
las cifras son asombrosas
y ni siquiera tenemos que mirar tan lejos.
Si miramos a nuestro alrededor, aquí en EE. UU.,
un estudio reciente informó que en el 2030 necesitaremos 100 000 cirujanos más
para tan solo hacer frente a la demanda de procedimientos quirúrgicos rutinarios.
Al ritmo que vamos, no llegaremos a esos números.
Como cirujana, este es un problema global que me molesta.
Me molesta mucho,
porque he visto de primera mano
cómo la falta de acceso a servicios de salud seguros y asequibles
puede arruinar la vida de la gente común.
Si eres un paciente que necesita una operación
y no hay un cirujano disponible,
te quedan opciones realmente difíciles:
esperar, viajar,
o no tener operación alguna.
Entonces, ¿cuál es la respuesta?
Parte de Uds. llevan encima parte de esa solución hoy:
un teléfono inteligente, una tableta, una computadora.
Porque para mí,
la tecnología de la comunicación digital tiene el poder de hacer mucho más
que permitirnos comprar en línea,
conectarnos en plataformas de redes sociales y mantenernos actualizados.
Esta puede ayudarnos a resolver algunos de los problemas clave que enfrentamos,
como la falta de acceso a servicios quirúrgicos vitales.
Y hoy me gustaría compartir con Uds.
un ejemplo de cómo creo que podemos hacer eso posible.
La historia de la cirugía está llena de avances
de cómo la ciencia y la tecnología pudieron ayudar a los cirujanos
a enfrentar sus mayores desafíos.
Si retrocedemos varios cientos de años,
una comprensión de la microbiología
llevó al desarrollo de técnicas antisépticas,
que jugó un gran papel para asegurar
que los pacientes pudieran seguir vivos después de la cirugía.
Avanzamos unos cientos de años
y desarrollamos cirugía mínimamente invasiva o artroscópica,
que combina tecnología de video e instrumentos de precisión
para hacer que la cirugía sea menos invasiva
Y más recientemente, muchos de Uds. conocerán la cirugía robótica,
y lo que la robótica trae a la cirugía es muy parecido a
la maquinaria automatizada moderna, ultraprecisión,
la capacidad de llevar a cabo procedimientos a escalas más pequeñas
con un grado de precisión que incluso supera la mano humana.
Pero la cirugía robótica también introdujo algo más a la cirugía:
la idea de que un cirujano, en realidad,
no tiene que estar al lado de la cama del paciente para prestar atención,
que podría estar mirando una pantalla
e instruir a un robot a través de una computadora.
Llamamos a esto "cirugía remota".
Nos incumbe a nosotros
encontrar soluciones que den respuestas de una manera rentable y escalable,
para que todos, sin importar dónde estén en el mundo,
puedan abordar estos problemas.
¿Y qué si les dijera
que realmente no se necesita un robot de un millón de dólares
para ofrecer una cirugía remota?
Que solo se necesita un teléfono, una tableta o una computadora,
una conexión a internet,
un colega de confianza en el terreno
y un ingrediente mágico:
un software colaborativo de realidad aumentada.
Usando este software colaborativo de realidad aumentada,
un cirujano experto ahora puede transportarse virtualmente
a cualquier entorno clínico
simplemente usando su teléfono o tableta o computadora,
y puede interactuar visual y prácticamente en una operación
de principio a fin,
guiando y asesorando a un médico local a través del procedimiento paso a paso.
Bueno, ya vale de explicarlo,
ahora me gustaría mostrarlo.
Ahora vamos a estar en directo con el Dr. Marc Tompkins,
cirujano ortopédico de la Universidad de Minnesota.
Él va a realizar una cirugía artroscópica para nosotros,
una cirugía mínimamente invasiva de rodilla,
y quisiera aclarar que
este paciente ha dado su consentimiento para que se emita su operación.
También me gustaría señalar que, por cuestiones de tiempo,
solo vamos a seguir los primeros pasos,
realizados al paciente
e identificando solo algunos hitos anatómicos clave.
Hola, Dr. Tompkins, ¿me escucha?
Dr. Mark Tompkins: Buenos días, Nadine.
Nadine Hachach-Haram: Todos los de TED saludan.
Audiencia: Hola.
NHH: Muy bien, Dr. Tompkins, comencemos.
Comencemos con nuestras incisiones y dónde vamos a hacer esto,
a ambos lados del tendón rotuliano.
Y, si puede hacer sus incisiones allí y allí,
eso debería llevarnos a la rodilla.
MT: Está bien, voy a entrar.
NHH: Genial.
Así que ahora estamos entrando en la articulación.
Y ¿por qué no vamos y echamos un rápido vistazo al menisco?
MT: Perfecto.
NHH: Así que podemos ver que hay una pequeña rasgadura en el menisco,
pero el resto se ve bien.
Y si le da la vuelta y se dirige a esta dirección,
siga mi dedo,
echemos un vistazo rápido al LCA y al LCP.
Este es su LCA allí, que se ve bastante sana,
no hay problemas allí.
Así que acabamos de identificar ese menisco pequeño rasgado ahí,
pero, por lo demás, el líquido que rodea la articulación se ve bien también.
Está bien, muchas gracias, Dr. Tompkins. Gracias por su tiempo.
Le dejo continuar.
Que tenga un buen día. Adiós.
(Aplausos)
Así que espero, a través de esta demostración simple,
ilustrarles cuán poderosa puede ser esta tecnología.
Y me gustaría señalar que no he usado ningún equipo especial,
solo mi computadora portátil y una cámara web realmente simple.
Estamos muy acostumbrados a usar la tecnología digital
para comunicarnos por voz, texto y video,
pero la realidad aumentada puede hacer algo mucho más profundo.
Permite que dos personas interactúen virtualmente
de una manera que simula cómo colaborarían en persona.
Poder mostrarle a alguien lo que quieres hacer,
ilustrando, demostrando y gesticulando,
es mucho más poderoso que solo decirlo.
Y puede ser una gran herramienta de aprendizaje,
porque aprendemos mejor a través de la experiencia directa.
Y ¿cómo esto marca una diferencia en todo el mundo?
Bueno, de vuelta en mi hospital de enseñanza,
hemos usado esto para apoyar a los hospitales del distrito local
para proporcionar cirugía de cáncer de piel y tratamiento de trauma.
Ahora los pacientes pueden acceder a la atención a nivel local.
Esto reduce su tiempo de viaje, mejora su acceso,
y ahorra dinero.
Incluso hemos comenzado a ver su uso en el cuidado de heridas con enfermeras
y en la gestión ambulatoria.
Más recientemente, y bastante emocionante,
se usó para apoyar a un cirujano en la extirpación de un riñón con cáncer.
Y me gustaría compartir con Uds. un video muy rápido aquí.
Me disculpo por algunas de las imágenes horripilantes.
(Video) Doctor 1: OK. Muéstrame de nuevo.
Doctor 2: Si ve aquí,
esa es la parte superior, la parte más externa del tumor.
Doctor 1: Sí.
Doctor 2: Entonces tiene 3 cm de profundidad,
así que esto debería ser de 3 cm.
Doctor 1: Sí, sí.
Doctor 2: Bien, entonces necesita obtener un margen de 3,5.
Doctor 1: Lo voy a mostrar de todos modos
y dime lo que piensas al respecto.
NHH: También estamos viendo el uso de esta tecnología a escala mundial,
y una de las historias más conmovedoras que puedo recordar
es del pueblo de Trujillo al norte de Lima en Perú,
donde esta tecnología fue utilizada para hacer
cirugías de labio y paladar hendido a niños,
niños de familias pobres sin acceso a un seguro de salud.
Y en esta ciudad, había un hospital con una cirujana
trabajando duro para brindar esta atención,
la Dra. Soraya.
La Dra. Soraya estaba luchando contra la gran demanda
de su población local, y contra el hecho de que
no estaba específicamente entrenada en este procedimiento.
Y así, con la ayuda de una organización benéfica,
pudimos conectarla con un cirujano especialista en hendiduras en California,
y con esta tecnología, pudo guiarla a ella y a sus colegas
en el procedimiento paso a paso,
guiarlos, entrenarlos y enseñarlos.
En unos meses,
pudieron realizar un 30 % más de operaciones
con menos y menos complicaciones
Y ahora la Dra. Soraya y su equipo pueden realizar estas operaciones
de forma independiente, competente y con confianza.
Y recuerdo una cita de una madre que dijo:
"Esta tecnología dio a mi hija su sonrisa".
Para mí este es el verdadero poder de esta tecnología.
La belleza es que rompe los límites.
Trasciende todas las dificultades tecnológicas.
Conecta a las personas. Democratiza el acceso.
El Wi-Fi y la tecnología móvil están creciendo rápidamente,
y deberían desempeñar un papel impulsando la atención quirúrgica.
Incluso la hemos visto usarse en zonas de conflicto
donde existe un riesgo considerable en conseguir cirujanos especialistas.
En un mundo donde hay más dispositivos móviles
que seres humanos,
realmente tiene un alcance global.
Por supuesto, todavía tenemos un largo camino
antes de poder resolver el problema de dar cirugía a 5000 millones de personas,
y desafortunadamente,
algunas personas aún no tienen acceso a internet.
Pero las cosas se mueven rápidamente en la dirección correcta.
El potencial para el cambio está ahí.
Mi equipo y yo estamos haciendo crecer nuestra huella global,
y estamos empezando a ver el potencial de esta tecnología.
A través de la tecnología digital,
a través de dispositivos simples y cotidianos que damos por sentados,
a través de dispositivos del futuro,
realmente podemos hacer cosas milagrosas.
Gracias.
(Aplausos)